pressure is what counts when you're
exercising pressure on the foot and the
joints Maximilian mulund his startup
company have invented a shoe sole that
measures the pressure on the human foot
while standing running jumping or skiing
in there's all this eps and 13 pressure
sensors in the soul itself and a
movement sensor record the data
afterwards you can display the data in
graph form alpha Daae todavia to elysian
the shoe soles and the accompanying
computer software now costs a stiff
2,000 euros but that price is going to
get lower and those with a passion for
jogging will soon be able to use an app
to check whether they're running
correctly fitness is in fashion millions
of people are trying to live healthier
and get more exercise they use modern
wireless technology to do things like
count how many steps they take in a day
unsworn from it builds incentive to
exercise more to walk more to walk to
the next bus stop before getting on and
get off one step earlier and walk the
rest of the way ordinary stuff at the
end of the day works for me put your
phone on wish I was hospital Lenny when
I finish working out I keep a record of
it I just have to push a button and then
I go home and plug a USB stick into my
pc and I can upload the data the shoe
sole sensors don't require any cables so
far most of the sales have been to
hospitals and rehab centers to better
monitor patients recovery to make all
this possible the sensors need to
collect a lot of data the creators are
well aware of the potential dangers
probably Martha's with Natalie stuff the
problem is when this kind of personal
data becomes accessible in an open
healthcare system then there's a danger
it could be used to determine insurance
tributions yeah anchored Bearden that
means in the future someone who doesn't
exercise as much as the health insurance
company recommends could end up paying
more for insurance but for now the
startup company just wants to profit
from the fitness trend